- [Announcer] In a city
that loves its bikes,
there is one man looking out for the rest.
One man, brave enough to
bring bike thieves to justice.
A man, the city calls, bike Batman.
- In reality, I'm just an engineer.
Back in the early 2000's,
I started really noticing,
you know, there was a lot of bike theft.
I remember I had a set of
wheels stolen, and I was livid,
but I was super poor, there
was nothing to do, you know,
I couldn't recover them.
It was so frustrating for me,
knowing that the police are
so busy with so many other
crimes in Seattle, that there
was nobody following up
on these minor incidents.
- [Announcer] Enough was
enough, he realized he needed to
take the law into his owns hands,
and he had the perfect plan.
- I would best describe bike
index as a data base, um,
that allows you to register your bicycle.
It's a great way to
search for stolen bikes.
The way that it works for me,
is as I'm perusing craigslist,
I'll notice a fishy ad, and
I will immediately open up
bike index, and do a quick
search for any bikes that
have been stolen in that geographic area.
The first time that I recovered a bike,
I had no idea what I was doing.
I drove after work to go meet
this guy, and it wasn't one
person I was meeting, it
was three, and I told them,
you know guys, the cops are
on their way I just called ‘em.
This bike is stolen,
and you're not gonna be
leaving with it.
Eventually I threw the bike in my truck,
burned out, returned
the bike, it felt great.
- [Announcer] What began
as a simple plan to help
a fellow cyclist, took
on a life of it's own.
Seattle's own bike vigilante, was born.
- We were able to recover,
high 30's or low 40's of bikes.
I'm not entirely sure
when the bike vigilante
had become a thing.
It was probably when the
bike Batman moniker was given
to me, and this is just
something, you know, I like doing.
I don't need, or want,
you know, any recognition.
Just doing good is essentially, you know,
how I try to live my life.
- [Announcer] And thanks to bike Batman,
the cyclists of the Emerald
City, can rest easy,
once more.